Det finns ju så många olika delar av det som jag tycker är helt skema.
Det finns verkligen så många.
Jag tror inte du förstår hur sjuklivsmedelsbranschen är.
Det är helt...
Man blir lite mörkrad faktiskt.
Berätta för oss, berätta för oss det du kan berätta.
Nu kommer det.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Jacob Hillestad till podden från Out of Home.
Du har precis kommit in i podden med mycket negativ energi.
Du spillde ut lite kaffesump, kaffet var slut, livet är för jävligt.
Jag kan tycka om det, att vi går in i ett poddavsnitt med svär, ångest och irritation.
Så jag hoppas vi får ett riktigt konfliktfyllt avsnitt här som vi båda går ifrån med ångestkänslor i magen.
Hur mår du idag Jacob?
Det kan ju bara bli bättre nu då kan man säga.
Vi får se.
Ja, det var ju, vi har faktiskt precis flyttat till ett nytt kontor också.
Så det var ju kaffesumpen i rätt ner nu på nya golvmatten här.
Men jag får skämmas för det sen.
Och du tittar dit bort lite då och då, ligger den kvar där?
Ja, jag ser att kaffet står och brygger också.
Jag fick ju aldrig min kopp, så det kan vara så att jag får springa ut sen.
Ja, men det får man göra.
Och vi kommer inte heller klippa det, utan vi låter det bara vara tyst när det är två minuter, för att det passar på något sätt avsnittet.
Ja, då kan alla gå och hämta kaffe.
Ja, men det är en poddavsnitt med kaffe paus.
Ja, men jag gillar det.
Gott, innan vi flummar iväg för mycket, kan du inte ge oss en liten, liten, vi börjar med, liksom, out of home, vad är det för någonting?
Ja, vi är en matgrossist, ser vi, så att vi levererar mat till företag i stora partier, för det mesta, men ibland även små kartonger.
Så att det är väl en korta beskrivning igen.
Och en matgrossist, det är liksom inte, där får man inte handla som privata kron, utan det är till typ Storsök och, eller vilka är kunderna, är det där?
Ja men precis, det började ju egentligen med Storsök, café, restaurang, hotell.
Men sen, ge med att vi är också då en öppen matgrossist, som är byggd på e-handel, så har det liksom hittat in massa andra typer av kunder under årens lopp.
Så nu är det ju en väldig blandning av olika typer av verksamheter liksom, från då restauranger och caféer till föreningar, livsmedelsbutiker, kontor och arbetsplatser, produktionsanläggningar av massa olika gym och träningförening faktiskt också.
Ganska stor kategori.
Men får man handla som privatperson?
Nej, eller vi hade det innan att man fick det, lite grann, men det var aldrig något stor grej.
Vi öppnade också upp under covid i några månader, när det var svårt för folk att få hem mat.
Och det är inte praktiskt svårt, men det öppnade upp ännu mer komplexitet i en ganska redan komplex verksamhet, där vi har väldigt många olika typer av kunder.
Att lägga till privatpersoner kanske är något vi tittar på i framtiden, men just nu är det inte aktuellt.
Men det ni gör egentligen är att ni säljer mat i bulk.
Om jag skulle liksom hårddra det.
Ja precis, stora förpackningar med mat.
Det kan vara 10 kilo säckar med ris eller 6 kilo kaffe eller 10 kilo frys, kyckling, bröst.
Men det är också konsumentförpackade grejer till livsmedelsbutiker.
Men då är det det som kallas för DFB då med kanske 12 stycken i kaffe från Otli i en kartong, som skat i en butik.
Finns inte de kanalerna redan eller varför?
Och jag menar det på ett kärleksfullt sätt, men ska inte matbutiker redan ha någonstans de handlar?
Jo, men det finns ju egentligen en aktör idag.
Det är ju Axfood då som har en grossist som heter Dagab, som levererar till butiker, framförallt den egna butikern och Willys hemköp och Tempo och sådär.
Men de är också den enda grossisten som levererar till andra butiker, fria butiker.
Ica levererar ju bara till sig själva, Coop levererar bara till sig själva, från sina lager.
Men finns det bara en matgrossist i hela Sverige, förutom er?
Ja det fanns en till för 2-3 år sedan som hette Bergendals.
Ja okej okej.
Men sen köpte Dagab Bergendals då, för ett par år sedan.
Så nu finns det bara en.
Så om du har en matbutik som inte är i en av de här kärdorna då, så är det ju i stort sett bara Dagab kan vända dig till, tills nu.
Hahaha, nu jävlar.
Nu händer det.
Men ni har funnits ett tag, ni drog igång lite på riktigt kan man säga typ 2015.
Men då var du första och enda anställda.
Ja precis, eller jag började i april och sen kom det in en till kille som heter Micke som skötte inköp och då gjorde vi allt där på två personer ett tag och sen så blev det fler, sakta men säkert.
Då hade vi bara, i stort sett kaffe och kryddor i certimentet och ganska snabbt så kom det in fler leverantörer, Cloetta, Salt och Kvarn, Oatly och några av de första efter det.
Vi hade kanske 300-400 artikelnummer då och så körde vi allt med postnord från Uddevalla där lagret låg.
Sammanfall faktiskt, det är inte så många som kanske vet att de jobbar med 3PL men de är ju svinduktiga.
Ligger ni fortfarande i Uddevalla eller?
Nej, vi växte ur det 2018.
Flyttade vi ner till Helsingborg med lagret och där fick vi tillgång till kyl och frys i samma laglokal.
Innan dess hade vi bara torrvaror.
Så hösten 2018 startade vi upp med färskvaror och frysda produkter.
Då gick vi ut under våren och snackade med alla stora leverantörer på frys och färsk, typ guldfågeln, kronfågeln, Findus, Aala och så vidare.
Så valde vi egentligen ut en per kategori där i början.
Så startade vi upp det där i september då.
Det gick första tempererade leveransen ut ifrån Helsingborg.
Jag bara tänker att varumärkena måste tycka att det här är lite nice.
Det känns ju som att på senare år så är det Icas egna sortiment i hela ICA och det är typ Coopas egna sortiment i hela Coop.
Det måste vara lite skönt för varumärkena att få en kanal direkt till det stora business to business-klivet.
Men vad är er affärsmodell där?
För ni hanterar, jag trodde först att ni bara skickade direkt att ni var någon sorts plattform, men det är ni inte, ni är en hel lager hanterings.
Det måste vara rätt krångligt.
Det är ju många som missförstår det.
En av de stora grejerna vi gör, och en av de stora grejerna en grossist gör, är att effektivisera logistik.
Det är en av de viktigaste grejerna som Autobom gör.
Vi köper in stora partier från direkt från producent, och sen packar vi mixpallar blandat till olika typer av kunder.
Att ha en egen logistik är ju det som är det stora värdet i Autobom.
Men som då inne på innan så leverantörsamarbeten har varit superviktigt för oss sedan början.
Vi har ju egentligen inga säljare, utan det är ju leverantörerna som är ut och pratar med kunderna hela tiden, och säljer sina egna produkter.
Då är vi ett av flera val som kunderna kan handla produkterna genom.
Av olika anledningar så rekommenderar de oss ibland, eller lyfter oss som det här alternativet.
Då hittar de in till oss och lägger en order, och oftast så får de med sig fler varor på den beställningen.
Så det är en viktig del av vad vi gör, att vi hjälper producenter eller leverantörer med en oberoende försäljningskanal utan ENV, där de kan lita på att det är deras grejer som levereras.
Och att de vet vad vi tar betalt av kunderna, så att de kan gå ut till en kund vart som helst i Sverige och säga att här är min produkt, den kostar såhär mycket, inklusive logistik, ut i dig.
Det kan man inte hos någon av de andra kursisterna.
Man vet inte vad sin egen produkt kostar.
Jag vet inte om det finns fler branscher där det funkar så, men där det finns så många tusen säljare som säljer produkter som de inte riktigt vet vad de kostar.
Hur menar du då?
Om du går ut till en restaurang till exempel och ska sälja ett paket med kanel.
Som man gör.
Ja precis.
Det kostar alltifrån 60 spänn till 200 spänn.
Det är ganska stort spann mellan den kunden som har det bästa priset och den som har det sämsta priset.
Då har du menat att säljarna går ut och säljer in varumärket, men de vet inte vilka volymer kunden kommer köpa och därför blir det svårt att ta förhandlingsfrågan på plats.
Det är en grusist i vägen som sätter ett pris.
Det priset är de som äger som grusist.
Det priset ska ju innefatta logistiken.
Det är svårt då om du är en leverantör och ska sälja din produkt, att gå ut i en restaurang eller ett kontor eller en butik och liksom, här är min produkt men jag vet inte riktigt vad den kostar för dig.
Men den är ju väldigt bra.
Den är grym.
Det blir svårt då att fånga upp köpsignalerna som kommer, att sammanfatta den här.
Det bör du gärna ha.
Men vad kostar den?
Ja, det får du fråga din grusist.
Det där är en ganska spännande interaktion som sker.
Men betyder det att sätter varumärkena då priserna på er sajt?
Nej, men vi är transparanta med de priserna som vi sätter, vilket gör att de vet exakt hur vi tar betalt.
Då kan de gå ut och säga att kanelen kostar 59,90.
Hur många kartonger vill du ha?
Sen är det inte alltid så det funkar, men ibland.
När man går in här så verkar det som att den här med pristransparens är ett starkt argument.
Men var det här tanken från början, eller var det bara från början att vi testar att sälja käk?
Och se vad som händer.
Har affärsidén vuxit fram eller fanns det en stor skal i plan?
För nu omsätter ni exa antal 100 miljoner och plöjer på, men från början var ni ju du och Micke.
Nej, men det var ju flera i bakgrunden också som...
Skit i dem, det var du och Micke som var det.
Nej, men det började ju väldigt mycket med just det.
Att det fanns ett tydligt problem, det finns en massa säljkårar som besöker kunder och man vet inte riktigt hur priset är.
Det är svårt att göra riktig försäljning då.
Man vet heller inte om kunden får rätt produkt.
Det kan vara så att de beställer ett varumärke och får ett DNV, det är liksom ett private label från Grucisten.
Så det sker en massa samla grejer därute.
Det var en viktig grej från början, det som har växt fram under tiden är ju att i takt med att vi har listat på alla de här leverantörerna och produkterna, så har leverantörerna kommit till oss med helt andra behov.
Typ såhär, talljhandeln.
Det är liksom en kategori av kunder som inte riktigt vet vad de ska vända sig till.
De har liksom en cassadinjär med choklad och dryck.
Det finns liksom ingen tydlig grossist de kan vända sig till för att handla de grejerna.
Eller fackhandeln med bygghandel, där man ställer ut pallar med kaffe på golvet.
Det finns massor med konstiga, i den situationstecken, kunder därute som köper livsmedel.
De har liksom hittat hem hos oss också på något sätt.
Och blivit en grej.
Så vi har ju, vi har egentligen hela tiden fokuserat på out of home.
Att vi ska bli så bra som möjligt, vi ska ha ett bra sortiment, en bra tydlig prisbild, en stark e-handel.
Och sen har leverantörerna liksom kommit med behovet hela tiden.
Det varje leverantör har ju ett helt unikt behov, ofta.
Det är någon typ av kund som är svår eller kundgrupp som de vill nå eller sådär.
Jag fattar.
Är detta något som du bryr dig om, tänkte jag säga.
Du har ju jobbat med detta i tio år liksom.
Är detta som en liten bebis till dig, eller tycker du mest att det är kul att företaget växer, eller vad är din bakgrund?
Varför bryr du dig om pristransparens inom grossistvärlden, inom mat?
Det är ju inte det jag vaknar upp på morgonen och tänker på.
Nej men det finns ju så många olika delar av det som jag tycker är helt skeva.
Finns det verkligen så många?
Ja men det...
Jag tror inte du förstår hur sjuk livsmedelsbranschen är.
Det är helt...
Man blir lite mörkrädd faktiskt.
Ja men berätta för oss, berätta för oss det du kan berätta.
Nu kommer det.
Ja nu kommer det.
Nej men för det första så tycker jag att det är tråkigt att livsmedelsproducenterna har det så jävla tufft att liksom alla som säljer produkter, Ica, Coop, Axfood jobbar väldigt hårt med sina EMB-produkter vilket i slutändan gör att livsmedelsproducenterna vi har i Sverige tappar liksom fotfestet.
Det tycker jag är jävligt tråkigt.
Jag tycker det är en av de roligaste grejerna med Out of Home att få förändra det.
Nu har vi livsmedelsbutiker som handlar varumärken av oss, där de handlar ett varumärke till ett lägre pris än vad de handlade ett EMB innan.
Det där blir man glad av.
Det är den ena grejen.
Den andra grejen är prisdifferentiering och hur stora priskorridorer det är i den här branschen.
Där vi har små kaféer, små butiker som betalar sjuka överpriser på produkter.
Det är en traditionell B2B-grossistmarknad där man har höga rekpriser, höga rabatter och utvalda produkter.
Det gör att många kommer till oss och har betalat 300 spänn för en produkt som vi säljer för 120 spänn.
Det finns ingen rimlighet i det.
Det är oftast de små kunderna som blir drabbade.
Det är butiker på landsbygden som ska betala 50% mer.
Det är samma produkt som Willys köper den produkten för.
Jag tycker att det inte är rimligt.
Det finns ingenting i logistiken som säger att det ska vara så.
Alltså så stor skillnad.
Jag fattar såklart att det ska vara en skildad men inte 50%.
Jag skickar också hela lastbilar till Stockholm och jag skickar två pall till Åmål.
Så stor är inte skillnaden i logistikprocent.
Jag tycker det är en vacker mission eller vad vi ska kalla det.
Jag tycker att inköp och sånt är kul.
Har ni ett rullande inköpsläge från alla de här varumärkena eller köper ni upp, här är 1000 kilo kyckling, det blir inte så jävla mycket för er.
Här är 10 000 kilo kyckling som ska in i ett litet parti som ni behöver få sålt.
Köper ni typ restlager eller överlager eller har ni bara ett ständigt flöde?
Det händer att vi köper överlager men för det mesta så är det ett ständigt flöde.
Det är ett jämnt flöde av mat så vi snurrar lagret kanske en gång i månaden i genomsnitt.
Varje dag så har vi två stycken operationella inköpare, där den ena också är inköp-
och logistikchef, så har de hand om logistiken.
Men de får ju upp förslag på vad de ska köpa in varje dag baserat på efterfrågan och prognos i det här inköpssystemet.
Så genererar man det inköpet och skickar iväg det.
Så det är kanske 20-50 inköp per dag någonstans där.
Ni har ju ett jävla fint bolag.
Det taktar ju liksom på i rätt bra takt.
Normalt sett så tycker jag, fan vad mycket beröm du får här nu, men normalt sett så tycker jag att sådana här bolag som har problematiken att ni måste få in både leverantörer och kunder, de tenderar ju att vara minusbolag.
När man skalar så kostar det pengar att driva in kontakter från båderhåll och man ska skala upp.
Ni har ju en rätt tråkig logistikkedja med både kylvaror och saker som tar slut i lager.
Då menar jag som har bäst före datum och liknande.
Men ni har ju inte särskilt stora förluster.
Vad fan om ni inte gick plus några kronor här i senast eller nåt sånt där.
Jag har det inte exakt i huvudet.
0,1 procent.
Fan ni är som gymkompanjeriet.
Men ni har liksom hållit er jävligt lin där.
Vad är det som gör att ni inte har de här katastrofala förlusterna som typ mathem eller liknande.
Jag fattar att det är lite skillnade, men vad är det som gör att ni ändå lyckas där?
Jag tror att vi har varit väldigt snåla hela tiden.
På gott och ont liksom.
Vi är alla extremt operationella.
Vi sitter liksom allihopa och gör operationella saker 95 procent av tiden.
Vilket gör att vi kan hålla vår overhead låg.
Vi jobbar med tre p.l på lager och logistik.
Det flyter hela tiden med vår tillväxt.
Vi behöver inte tänka på det så mycket.
Annars behöver vi ibland flytta lager när vi växer ur dem.
Det är framför allt det att hålla en så låg overhead som möjligt.
Sen att ha såklart bra logistik.
Det är det absolut viktigaste.
Ju mer vi kan skicka på varje lastbil till Stockholm eller Göteborg varje dag, desto lägre blir kostnaden per pallplats.
Det är det som avgör hela den här fighten.
Om den fighten är så stark, just logistikregeln, hur kommer det sig att ni inte äger den själva utan har ett DPL på just den punkten?
Det är just det med tillväxt.
Vi hade ju inte gjort något annat än att anställda och rådda till personal och lastbilar och allt vad det hade krävt för att ha det in-house.
Så i den situationen vi är i där vi förväntas växa närmsta för alltid, då är det svårt att se på ett scenario att det här lagret ser ut att vara rätt storlek.
Eller så här många lastbilar behöver vi eller så här många personer i plocket.
Så där vi är nu så är det inte riktigt aktuellt.
Vad är det för bolag i grunden här?
Vilka är det som äger det här bolaget, vilka är det som grundar det, vilket är teamet som råddar det och vad är hela upplägget här på Öre och Hum?
Det är ju drygt 50 ägare, för det mesta privatpersoner, en fond.
Vi har ingen verklig huvudman, utan det är många olika privatpersoner av olika bakgrunder och så många personalen.
Fan, coolt.
Är det bara random folk som har fått vara med?
Ja, men det är ju från hur vi startade ur ett annat bolag egentligen från första början 2015.
Då speglades vår ägarbiljk med det bolaget vid den tidpunkten.
Så det har tillkommit några fler, men det är samma gäng i stort.
Är det liksom du och Bettan och Lotta och Nisse och Pelle, eller är det liksom vanliga, missförstår vi rätt men det är liksom folk från stan typ, eller är det folk som faktiskt har drivit stora bolag innan och har investerat in i detta?
Det är framförallt folk som har drivit stora bolag innan och liksom har investerat, och vissa från branschen också, Lyssmärtsbranschen.
Men de flesta är inte från Lyssmärtsbranschen, utan kanske mer från E&L och andra sidor.
Hur länge ska du få köra på i den här rollen?
Det är en ganska stor skillnad på nu och för tio år sedan.
Det måste ha hänt ganska mycket.
Återigen, på det mest kärleksfulla sättet, hur stort är du kapabel att skala bolaget innan du känner att nej, fan, det här fattar jag ingenting av.
Ja, nej men det är klart man ställer sig den frågan.
Men vi har sex olika teams.
Vi har ekonomi, operations, KAM, e-handel, sedan har vi några som tar hand av våra leverantörer, och sedan har vi ett färskvarit team i Småland.
Och jag är också ledare för operations-teamet, där inköp, logistik och kundservice ingår.
Så det är egentligen två roller som jag jobbar med där.
Där sitter vi och funderar på när det är rätt läge att ersätta mig själv på den rollen.
Så att jag kan kanske jobba med andra grejer, som kanske försäljning och förhandling.
Det finns en massa grejer jag skulle kunna göra.
Men det är kul med operations tycker jag.
Det är så mycket som händer och det är så mycket man kan göra bättre.
Och det är också det som gör skillnad på bottenlinjen, liksom.
När man utvecklar nya funktioner eller hittar något sätt att bli av med någon kostnad.
Nu har vi precis en funktion som vi ska lansera idag, som har varit super efterfrågad länge av många, inklusive oss själva, som är att komplettera en order som den är lagd.
Det kommer ju vara en vinst för alla inblandade här.
För att kunderna kommer kunna lägga större order.
Jag bara älskar hur innu man är i systemet när det är det här man tar upp som exempel.
All cred, för jag fattar att det här är en grej, men det är ju ingen break it artikel.
Nej precis.
Det roliga är att alla de andra gussisterna har haft den här featuren i hela tiden, så det är bara att vi, jag vet att ni kör Magento också, men vi har ju behövt skriva om hela den delen för att få den här orderexporten och fatta att det finns en order till samma kund på samma dag med samma adress.
Vi kanske ska ta och lägga på de artiklarna där istället för att skapa en ny order, men det gör att vi skickar mindre pallar, vi får en effektivare logistik, kunderna får en faktura, de får också leveransen på ett snyggare sätt, de kan komma på två timmar senare att de behöver ditt gurka också, så de kan lägga till det.
Det blir en ganska liten, och som du säger, det är ingenting som hamnar någonstans, en nyhetsartikel, men det är en extremt stor påverkan för oss internt, för våra kunder och för vårt resultat, i att vi skickar färre orders åt alla.
Vi hatar det, vi beställer ju, vi har till exempel en svensk grossist, vi beställer komplementprodukter ifrån, och då kanske vi gör 2-3 order om dagen där.
Och de precis som vi hade gärna haft en sådan funktion, för att de enda som tjänar pengar på detta är ju fraktbolaget, som får tre olika bokningar, men ingen har sådana jävla funktioner, men det måste hålla åren, fan det är ett jävla komplex om du ska skriva om det där.
Jag gissar att ni har hållit på med det ett tag.
Ja men det blir ju också dubbla orderstartsavgiften med vårt lager, som är 3PL, det blir liksom alldeles dubbelt.
Sånt är kul, och liksom lansera och förbättra hela tiden.
Men vad gör du på dagarna liksom, utöver sådana här stora groundbreaking-uppfinningar?
Hur stort är era team?
Vi är 25 personer.
Det är inte så jävla många på, vad omset ni, 300 någonting.
Ja, 450 år kanske.
Ja, jag diffade bara på 150 miljoner, jag förstår det.
Nej men det är, jag är ju involverad i så mycket jag orkar, antagligen för mycket.
Jag tycker ju om de här detaljerna.
Och jag tror också att det är där problemen sitter liksom och lösningarna.
Att hela tiden, vi har haft som ledo de senaste tre åren att minska komplexitet.
Det är så otroligt komplext att jobba på AtoFo.
Det är så många system, det är så många transportörer, du ska hålla koll på temperaturer och batcher.
Vi kan liksom inte ha 17 betal lösningar.
Det funkar inte.
Det är så komplext redan att ska man klara av att hantera en kundservice så måste man bryta ner det till så enkla beståndsdelar som möjligt.
Det jobbar vi mycket med.
Jag har försökt att hålla mig borta, men jag har kommit fram till att jag vill och jag tror det är bra att jag är inne och pillar i detaljerna.
För att någonstans är det out of home som tjänst, det måste vara bra hela vägen.
All kommunikation, hemsidan, order bekräftelser, hur vi pratar i kundservice, allt måste hänga ihop.
Många av de där grejerna är sånt man behöver se över regelmunder tror jag, och det är väldigt få som lägger så mycket tid på det.
Tycker dina kollegor att du är precis skitjobbig?
Har de frågat om du kan inte ha ett eget rum där borta?
Jo, nej men jag tänkte inte att jag var sån innan, men jag har tydligen åsikter om precis allting.
Det är verkligen på gott och ont, men det är kul.
Varje dag är det olika.
Vem är jag?
Precis, nej men alla.
Det har ju liksom också blivit en del av kulturen, att alla hela tiden förbättrar och hittar problem och komplexa saker som vi gör enkla.
Men jag tror att det hänger ihop det där också.
Men finns det inte en fara i att det blir för mycket din åsikt som spelar roll?
Om du ska in och peta.
Jag är ju väldigt tvärtom, jag har ju typ inga åsikter om någonting, men alla mina kollegor är ju väldigt, om man ska gå in lite i den här boken så är de ju väldigt blå, de är väldigt detaljstyrda.
Så att ofta, de har liksom koll på allting och jag är mer såhär, ja det är trevligt om vi får iväg saker fort.
Ja men det är klart, det är två olika skolor.
Det finns ju liksom olika fördelar med varje.
Men blir det inte, blir det inte Jakob, vad skulle Jakob tycka?
Är du inte rädd att de håller sig tillbaka i sin kreativa process så att säga?
Det finns säkert en del problem med det ja, absolut, men sen så är det ju, det är inte så att jag någonsin säger att någonting, det där gjorde du dåligt, utan...
Säger du aldrig att någonting är dåligt?
Jag säger varje dag att, fan vad kaste jag är på det här, löst något annat.
Det finns två skolor därmed.
Jag är med av skolan att det är rätt lätt att göra saker okej, bra, och det är så många som inte gör det okej bra.
I B2B, erosistbranschen, så kommer man rätt långt på att vara okej.
Om allt är okej, då är man jävligt bra, när det är B2B.
Och det är så många delar out of home att, ja men som sagt, följesel, det är så många ställen som man kan göra okej.
Att välja att raka, göra någonting lite bättre.
Det kan inte bli sämre liksom.
Jag måste nästan poängtera detta, för jag tror att folk som inte säljer B2B är inte medvetna om hur kass den världen är och hur fullkomligt meningslös vissa förbättringar kan tyckas men när alla, ni har säkert också sådant men när Pippolidé drog igång från kommuner och landsting och sånt där så var de ju så här hej vi vill köpa in detta, kan ni ta emot Pippolidé?
Och vi visste ju inte vad det var för några år sedan.
Så var det så här, ja det kan vi, vi sa ju bara ja för att få affären och sen gick man bara in och så var det liksom, det var ju inte svårt, det tog ju typ fem minuter att läsa.
Men de var ju så här, ah vi har frågat oss tio leverantörer, alla säger nej.
Du menar för att få in en hel regionsförsäljning, ah vi, det är lugnt, asså folk är, vi har inte fått svar på den här offerten på tio dagar, på riktigt.
Det är ett löpande, du bara skickar en fucking offertt, skriv tipsen och så är det klart.
Ja nej jag vet inte, det är bedrövligt.
Det är helt sjukt, det är så låg nivå ibland.
Ja nej kul att ni snor upp det där.
Ni har också köpt ett bolag som heter Smålandskafferi, jag har ingen koll på det sen innan men det verkar vara en grej när man köper bolag att allt skiter sig.
För att det är olika skolor, olika sätt, olika system.
Kan du inte berätta lite, jag är lite fascinerad av att köpa bolag, kan du inte berätta hur ni fick in det och fick det att funka?
Om ni fick det att funka.
Vi kom i kontakt med Smålandskafferi i höstas förra året och det var en stund efter att vi hade flyttat till Växjö och jag var med Lagret och de sitter ju där.
Vi konstaterade rätt snabbt att de är bra på allt som vi är dåliga på och vi är bra på allt som de är dåliga på.
Vad var ni dåliga på?
Färsikvaror framförallt och sälj, direkt sälj.
De har ju haft bara telefonförsäljning i princip.
De ringer alla sina kunder varje vecka och säljer varor.
Och det har de gjort i tio år och omsätter 50 miljoner på det.
Och det är en av våra svagheter.
Vi hade ju kunnat sälja mer om vi hade haft säljare, såklart.
Och den där frågan har man ju ställt sig många gånger.
Ska man ha en säljare eller inte?
Och det är ju någon slags principiell fråga någonstans också.
Går man den vägen så är man ju till slut en traditionell grusist.
Med liksom fält säljare i hela Sverige och tjänstebilar och allt vad det innebär liksom.
Ja och då måste vi höja priserna.
Och så blir det liksom, då blir det inte det som som att och för hon är.
Men just med färskvaror.
Och då tänkte ni, ja ja, så vi kör på det.
Ja nej men just med färskvaror är det lite annorlunda.
För den måste du ha.
Den måste snurra så snabbt.
För många grejer håller det liksom i sju dagar.
Då måste du ha någon som kan liksom, ja men jag har fläskfilé här med fem dagar kvar.
Då måste du kunna slå ett samtal och få ut den.
Och det är de grymma på.
Och vi kan ju sälja den fläskfilén hela tiden.
Till alla våra butikskunder.
Så det har ju blivit en bra fördel för oss båda.
De har ju fått en e-handel som de kan hänvisa till.
För det har de inte haft sedan innan.
Och vi har fått ett team som driver ett jättefint, lokalt färsakvårdsortiment.
Fast att allt finns på vår hemsida och på vårt lager.
Så vi kan sälja de produkterna till alla våra kunder.
Så det har funkat skitbra.
Ungefär som vi hade tänkt oss.
Sen har ju massor med grejer gått fel och så där under överflytten.
Vi flyttade in dem i vårt lager i mars.
Vi gjorde ju en stor lagerflytt 2023.
Och det här var liksom, det var en lastbil som gick över.
Som var liksom direkte.
Så det ändå snuttrade så snabbt.
Det var ingen stor grej med själva flytten.
Det var ju snarare mycket arbete i förhand med att synka kundlistor, lägga upp produkter, leverantörer, publicera produkter med text och bild.
Jag tror vi har lagt upp 2500 produkter i år hittills.
Och då har vi skrivit texter och fixat bilder på alla.
Det var ju ett jättejobb.
Men nu är vi i kapp.
För första gången i allt av deras historia så har vi ingen backlogg på produkter och leverantörer att lägga upp.
Så det känns otroligt faktiskt.
Hur stora kan ni bli, hur stor är den här branschen?
Man har ju liksom ingen uppfattning om det här.
Nej men den är ju så enorm att det inte ens är nåt att tänka på det liksom.
Och vi är ju inte ens en fel leverans för de stora krististerna än så länge.
Så vi bryr oss inte så mycket om det.
Utan vi kör på.
Och vi gör Autofoom så bra som möjligt så får de kunderna som tycker om oss och de leverantörerna som fattar grejen växa med oss.
Men ni gör egentligen, nu säger du att de här är säljare, men jag upplever att de inte är så traditionella säljare.
Det är inte så att de åker runt och besöker alla ställen, utan de kanske mer jobbar efter kundlistor som finns lite grann.
Men normalt sett när jag sitter i de här samtalen så är det väldigt mycket diskussioner om marknadsföring, eller bygga varumärke, eller skapa content, eller massa sådana här mer flummiga frågor kanske.
Ni jobbar ju i princip bara med rent ultrakonkreta grejer, alltså bygga funktion och logistik.
Visst är det så, ni gör inte allt det där andra.
Nej, vi gör ingen marknadsföring alls.
Utan vi har haft som princip från början att inte lägga pengar på saker som inte levererar ett direkt värde till kunderna.
Vi har haft okej rutiner på sökmotorsoptimering från dag ett.
Vi har skrivit produkttexter på ett visst sätt.
De flesta B2B-företag bryr sig inte så mycket om det där, bilder och texter.
De flesta B2B-företag har heller ingen öppen inge handel, utan du måste be en kundnummer som kommer med posten tre veckor senare.
Det har gjort det ganska enkelt, att ranka högt upp.
Alla produkter och kategorier lägger upp.
Nu har vi en filterfunktion på Out of Home, där man kan filtrera torrvaror från salt och kvan.
Då blir det en egen kategori.
Sen har du också kikärtor från salt och kvan.
Det blir en annan hudkategori, en annan h1.
Det blir sammantaget alla de här filtrerna, flera hundratusen kategorier som rankas, tillsammans med alla produkt sidor.
Det räcker för att driva rätt mycket nya kunder, som söker på stor pack, docco eller vad det nu är de är ut efter.
För då har vi antagligen en länk eller en kategori som är rimlig för den sökningen.
Men detta måste ju vara ett, alltså några få gånger i poddens historia så har jag tyckt att folk hade kunnat skala upp det så in i helvete.
Detta måste ju vara ett ganska sånt case.
Ni har ju gjort detta, ni har ju grunderna på plats.
Känns weird att säga att vi är ett bolag som omsätter 450 miljoner, men det är klart att ni har.
Ni fattar er business, men inom mat måste det handla om volym.
Det måste ju handla om volym.
Som du säger, om ni hade ökat till typ 3-5 miljarder så måste det vara sjukt mycket bättre.
Här måste ju någon kunna komma in och plöja in pengar och få ut till alla berörda att härifrån handla ner.
Varför gör ni inte den vägen?
Det är väl en del av den ägargruppen som vi har haft.
Att vi ska växa kontrollerat.
Vi ska inte göra minus 50% resultaten som många gör, utan vi ska ha en kontrollerad tillväxt som hela tiden förbättras lönsamhetsmässigt för varje år.
Det är också en grej som sätter sig i kulturen.
I hur man gör saker.
Vad är det som är så svårt med att få lönsamhet i mat?
Vi har ju sett lite exempel på företag som inte går så jävla bra.
Trots att det låter logiskt.
Är det för att ni säljer allt i bulk?
Är det hela grejen?
Det är olika grejer för oss och för sådana som Mathem till exempel.
Jag tror att det största är ju logistiken.
Det är jättesvårt att komma till den skalbarheten.
Att du kan räkna hem det stoppet.
När de beställer hem en matkasse för 500 spänn och så ska det levereras och de ska bära in den.
Du måste ha ett stor volym.
Många stopp på samma gata för att det ska löna sig.
Det är ju den ena grejen.
Sen är det det vi snackade om innan med overheads.
Vi hade kunnat vara 200 pers om jag sa ja till alla förslag på anställningen.
Det är ju jättelätt att göra det.
Vi hade säkert varit mycket större då också men det är en lite annan väg att gå som är mer riskfylld tror jag än att fortsätta göra det med så låg overhead som möjligt.
Men upplever du samma, vad ska vi kalla då, lite tråkiga svar?
För jag får ju ofta frågan sådär, ja hur ser det ut om fyra fem år?
Då är det såhär, ja vi gör väl samma sak fast 15 procent mer per år.
Är det så du också ser på framtiden för Out of Home?
Finns det någon sorts hockeykurva eller finns det någon sorts stora förändringar?
Eller är det bara såhär, vi ska mata på här i 10-15 år till och göra samma sak?
Men alltså det är ju, varje år ser ju så otroligt annorlunda ut.
Så det är som att vi är ett nytt bolag varje år känns det som.
På vilket sätt då?
Jo men såhär, i år har det varit färskvaror som har varit fokus liksom.
Året innan det var det lagerflytt.
Året innan det var det liksom alkohol eller det är alltid någon ny grej som händer.
Det är så sjukt mycket att göra.
Och det är så många olika projekt man liksom vill göra.
Att svårare är ju att liksom försöka sätta ner och bara göra en grej.
Inte försöka göra 17 grejer liksom.
Det går ju lite emot det jag sa innan om att allt ska vara ok.
Men det är väl, det är liksom frågan om man ska sätta ner och göra någonting riktigt bra någon gång.
Och inte bara ok.
Det finns, ja men Norge, Danmark är ju definitivt liksom länder vi pratar om.
Där man har ungefär samma problematik liksom med en grossist som styr allting.
Så det är intressant.
Men sen, det finns ju kunder som handlar för mer än vår omsättning.
Så vi, som jag sa innan, vi är så otroligt små.
Att såklart om vi börjar rikta oss lite mer mot kärlekunder, nu när vi börjar få fullsortiment, och riktigt med färskvarorna, så har vi möjlighet att jobba med stora riksdekanikärlekunder på ett annat sätt.
Som sagt, de är superstora jämfört med oss då.
Så det är klart att det kommer säkert att hända grejer där.
Har du stött på dina konkurrenter här, eller din konkurrent?
Det lät som att det finns typ en.
Men har ni stött på varandra någon gång?
Kan ni snacka trevligt med varandra eller tycker de illa om er?
Nej, jag vet inte.
De vet att vi finns ens, nej men det vet de väl.
Men ett av blivit inte så mycket kanske.
De har ingen piltavla med ansiktet på?
Nej, inget sånt?
Nej.
Okej, vad härligt att höra.
Du, nej fan jag vill ha en fråga till, kommer jag på, som jag tycker om.
Det här med privatperson.
Det är typ, Costco har ju kommit till Sverige.
Och det är ju typ, grossistköp fast med privatperson.
Om jag förstår det rätt fast man betalar någon sorts medlemsavgift och allt sånt där.
Är inte det lite write up your alley fast ni hade kunnat göra det med på svenska istället?
Men du har ju det här problemet med logistiken att det är aldrig värt att skicka någonting för 500 spänn med e-handel.
För hela frakten äter ju upp allt.
Men även om ni hade minimiköp på 10 000 spänn?
Jo, då hade det ju varit värt det.
Men så många privatpersoner finns ju inte som kan lägga en order för 10 000.
Men säger fem, det hade väl kunnat gå.
Men det finns ju så många andra grejer som vi kan göra med de här kunderna, kategorierna som vi jobbar med idag.
Det lockar inte jättemycket just nu.
Vad är en snittorder på en B2B kund inom det här?
Vi har en snittorder nu på 10.
Den har gått från 2 till 10 de här tio åren.
Men sen skiljer det sig jättemycket.
Vi har kunder som handlar för 2000 spänn och sen har vi de som handlar för 150 per order.
Det är ju såklart förvitt skilda logistikkostnader kopplade till de beställningarna.
Jakob, ett stort stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Det glädjer mig att det finns verksamheter därute som jobbar bara med funktion.
Det ger mig en lycka.
Jag tycker att allt ska vara så fint, att allt ska se bra ut, att allt ska framstå som.
Så det är jävligt skönt att säga, vad är er kärnverksamhet?
Det är få folk att köpa mer så man kan sätta mer på pallen, så det blir mer prisvärt.
Vilket jävla skönt mål att ha i livet.
Jag gillar det, det bara glädjer mig.
Stort tack för att du var med.
Tack själv.
Så är det ju i stort sett bara dagar vi kan vända det till.
Tills nu.
Nu, nu jävlar.
Nu händer det.